[Music]
the race for a coronavirus vaccine
is not just a matter of saving lives
it's also a matter of saving face for
some world leaders
as news broke this week the two vaccines
have reached 90
efficacy the incentive to speed up
trials is growing
russia and china are already rolling out
their vaccines to the public
before final testing is that safe
what efficacy rate is high enough what
level of side effects is acceptable
and how can users trust the vaccine
they're given
in a world brimming with disinformation
separating fact from fiction is
challenging
[Music]
well it's becoming like a bidding war
first the german us duo biontech and
pfizer announcing
its success of 90 percent then moscow
chimed in
reporting the same figure for its first
candidate that was monday
then the interim trial results on
wednesday showing russia's sputnik
vaccine is actually 92 percent effective
protecting people from covert it's
raising eyebrows among skeptics
but it's also raising hopes that we'll
have a vaccine by the end of the year
and the more vaccines the better
president vladimir putin says russia is
registering its third
vaccine against the coronavirus and
insists all of them are effective
the scientific community doesn't agree
and believes
studying mass inoculations is risky
the cameras are waiting
they've been promised a celebrity who's
ready to be filmed being given the
russian vaccine
sputnik 5.
enter blogger and bodybuilder alexander
spak
the eccentric social media star takes
one last selfie
before he's injected with a dose of the
still unproven vaccine
no one had to talk me into doing it it's
always good to be the first at something
i always had a negative view of
vaccinations but this is different
the doctors will keep an eye on
alexander for the next six months to
observe the effects of sputnik 5.
the russian blogger is enthusiastic to
be part of the program
and like so many other people he just
wants life to get back to how it was
done normally i travel a lot i want to
work normally to move around normally
i don't like the masks now i can get all
the medical treatments
and be one of the first to be really
free
batting off international criticism
russia rushed forward in the global race
for a coronavirus vaccine
[Music]
back in august sputnik 5 became the
world's first registered vaccine
but critically that was before the
results of the all-important phase 3
trials were published
president vladimir putin is eager to be
the man who presents the world with an
effective vaccine
that would come with guaranteed prestige
and of course profit
in mid-october he made another
announcement
the nova scobersk based vector center
has registered a second russian
coronavirus vaccine epi vac corona
meanwhile alexander spak waits to hear
whether sputnik 5 has provided him with
antibodies or not
ross hemka joins us from the vfa the
association of research-based
pharmaceutical companies
um all of these vaccines or many of them
now are sounding more and more promising
so
when final testing is over when or how
does production go ahead
well the production has already started
most companies
have produced components of the vaccine
already
at least one company has also reported
that they have at least one bet ready
for delivery
and with the components the other
companies will be able
to have finished products soon as soon
as they have an approval
well ready for delivery so uh hopes are
high but of course
we have to see the final tests um a top
army general behind the u.s vaccine
initiative anticipates the first
americans could also start receiving
covert 19 vaccines
next month what do you think about that
well the one company that has
was the first to report positive
efficacy
results they said that they now have to
wait for summer days
to complete the collection of safety
data
they need safety data from at least two
months
after the last shot from all the
participants
when they can hand them in the
application is complete then the
the fda in the us and the ema
in europe can start evaluating the
vaccine
and when they have a positive opinion
about it
and when there is an approval they can
start
so yes there is a chance to have
uh approval in december um we
rather more would expect it in early
january
and as far as production goes how
sufficient would you say
the global production capacity actually
is
well some months ago there has been an
estimate
that there is a global production
capacity
of something between two and four
billion doses of kovit19
vaccines that could be produced that's
quite a lot
but obviously it's we need even more
so companies have started to find
more contract manufacturers that produce
components for them
and they have also find other companies
where they can
license the wax into um
so that they can produce it as well e.g
in
australia or in south africa in japan
and so on
so most likely during 2021 the capacity
will
even increase what about the
infrastructure
some of these vaccines have to be stored
at extremely cold temperatures
well some vaccines indeed need
minus 70 degrees celsius but
fortunately some others that are also
very
far in their development they only
need a refrigerator so
we hope to hear of positive efficacy
data
in the next weeks and then this
could make the situation a bit easier
for those who have to organize
all the delivery things and the wh
o has organized
the kovacs facility as they call it
that's the kind of an organization that
buys from companies and then
distributes the doses they buy
between various countries that i have
signed in
and they make sure that a large share
goes to middle and low
lower and middle income countries so you
don't think those developing countries
will be
left at the back of the queue
at the moment it seems that the
industrialized
nations will most likely
be quicker with having enough for their
population
but on the other hand we also have
mechanisms
that make sure that the low and middle
income countries
will get their share at an increasing
share
as for example um
companies in india have licenses to mass
produce vaccine
and they have huge capacities when they
can
deliver um and they've announced that
they will
deliver in particular to low and
middle-income countries then
they will also have the vaccine they
need
and could you give us a an idea of how
much
the vaccine is actually going to cost
well some companies have uh mentioned
prices
some have already stated that
they will have differential prices so a
higher price industrial
in industrialized countries and
a lower price in low and middle-income
countries
for germany it appears that
the vaccination will be cheaper
than the ordinary influenza vaccination
that
people have every year so the prices are
really
oriented at the lower end and some
companies have stated that they will
orient their prices
uh at their uh at cost really at their
own manufacturing cost
wow impressive stuff thank you very much
for joining us today from the vfa
time to ask derek what he thinks about
the latest developments as always our
science correspondent is standing by to
field your questions on the coronavirus
here in south africa some of us who had
covid19 have experienced memory loss
is there any research on that cognitive
dysfunction
is one of the symptoms on the long list
of those associated with covet 19 that i
think
a lot of people really worry about in
some patients
infection with the virus can have
effects on on cognition
as well as on the sensory systems that
are tied to it
such as the sense of smell some
experience
delirium or say they still feel a
general sense of confusion
or or find it difficult to focus um
even long after other people who caught
the disease might have recovered from it
um the range of symptoms even has a name
people are calling it a covet brain fog
and and memory loss is being regularly
reported by people who experience it
a major recent study from the uk that
looked at the coronavirus and cognition
including some aspects of short-term
memory um
it was pretty disquieting though it's
it's one that i
i hasten to add has not yet been through
peer review
um the scientists behind it compared the
results of
over 80 000 british participants in a
nationwide
intelligence test and they correlated
that with data
on their covet 19 status so whether
they'd been
infected and if so how severe it was
and the researchers found among covet 19
patients
significant cognitive deficits including
even months later especially among those
who were hospitalized but even among
those who had
milder cases the hope however
is still that those deficits won't prove
lasting
you